Novak said you played the first two sets virtually perfect.
So, do you think those are two of the best sets you've ever played at Roland-Garros?
Well, of course I played at an amazing level of tennis.
For two sets and a half, I played great, honestly.
I can't say another thing.
It's impossible to have this score against him without playing great.
Yeah, I played a very good final.
I played at my highest level when I needed to play at my highest level,...
...so it's something that I am very proud of.
The personal satisfaction is big because under the circumstances that we played this Roland-Garros,...
...even if I played an amazing match this afternoon,..
...the conditions are not the conditions that I will choose to play in an event like this.
But, I was able to adapt well.
I was able to, as I said the first day,...
...to be positive in every circumstance that I was facing during the whole event.
Plan to accept all the challenges in terms of, sometimes  the feeling on the ball hasn't been great...
...because of the cold and everything.
But, I take it in a positive way.
I just tried to work every day with the right determination, looking for my goals.
I think it's one of the Roland-Garros that has a better personal value for myself.